Hôm nay, lấy ông không chung nhạm như thạch họ không chung ra lâu.
Để là người nạt thời có con nghĩa tôi cứ đồng ý,
phòng mình sẽ cạnh ra pháo.
Bây giờ mà sao, và gấp mà không nông tình ra ghét, chỉ sẽ có ra lâu.
Không được lợi trọng phía một là đồng ý, hãy là không lùng ý.
Hãy để nên là mọi người khá là bức sức.
Sẽ sao có bị đồng gia của lần chỉ, như là gần đây thì có đồng vừa dùng ra lâu tại Việt Nam đã có nhiều phản ứng trai chil,
so quành được ứng dụng này cập dịch yêu phản xí cụm mới.
Chả đó thì người dùng của phản đồng ý với cách các điều phản đều một tích tập sự giúp ra lâu.
Chằm đó thì có nhiều lợi dùng lên qua để việc tú tập và sự lửa cạnh nhận điều khóc chân thật.